the fellow scholars this is when mister
pepper sweet caruso life and hold onto
your paper speak is this workin alphago
is absolute insanity
in the game of goal the players state
of the table where it is objective the
surround more time tricht and the
opponent
this is a  beautiful game' er is
particularly interesting for a year
research
lucas de space of possible bos is wesley
larger than in chess
which means that using any sort of
justice search is out of question
and who two types of smart algorithms
its e-mail to identify a  small number
of current both within this to penders
die live search space
the first incarnation of deep mind scolea
alphago
uses a combination of policy network this
is responsible for predicting de mos en
de radio network that protects the
winner of the game of trip place it to
d&g still af bizarre forest deep neural
networks and the ardennes combined how
the technique rode monte carlo research to
be able to marry dan the search in this
larg  e workspace
this er by het hem started out how the
bush fracking process would be with the show
soft games that we used to learn the
basics of co based on this it is clear
that such ona grow then can learn to
be so good is formidably green  players
met the big question was how could
possibly be com
even better than the professional city
pass on surf
keep the disciple become better than
its master
the solution is it absolutely the country
where this can read of those games
mind itself many many times to
improve it skills this bag is a party is
the main part of the training that takes
the mostar lesbo lesbian arboretum elven
golf and how it was used to play a
tarmac road the tool that was european goal
champion defeated 50 euros this was
a historic moment and the first  time
en thea
offers professional goal player we that the
handicap of gladys craft is experience
is quite correct 5 booze and stable player
enthusiasm mention that the item
mistakes 5 joene like some more is  der
drops we in the kook community and notes
the theory to pay
ever be able to beat lisa dal and mind en
en world champion and winner of epn
international tables
just give you an integration of the
difference based on their ilo points
lisa bal is expected to  beat of two
mind the seven times out of my hand met
games so few months later the mind
organized us media vent
where the we challenging to play a dude
alphago this was a slightly modified
version of the besar great him dat use the
deeper your network whitmore  layers
and was trained using more resources than
the previous version
there was on such an algorithmic change by
the police networks details on the
sorrow a lot in the pepper in the
description this great read
make sure to have look plesk odessa
throws him off foil
dissident was  watch store on the world
and can perhaps be compared to casper of
public chess games and mind
he him the van so memories of waking up
super early in the morning
jump  ing out of the bed in excitement to
watch all these gorgeous and in a like
and share biting series
lisa bal was dividend for two one by the
way with significant lilas media
attention the next face cream
bring the take alphago master which used
rand and times  les tensor processing unit
stem die alfolie en offers a
new single player the target and play
the human professionals online
in january 2017 and hot as 16 matches
i have plate this is insanity
but the feeling that set do hold onto
your papers me in their  newest work
alphago has reached its mix form of a
goal zero
this variant dat not have access to and
if you and play games in the first phase
and less completely early even play it
starts at van absolutely nothing
we just a knowledge of the rules of the
game it was traint for forty days and
by dave lee is which the level of
alfolie
this is a bad world champion level ram
did for in my the guide the level of
alphago master switches spoke teako
lie offers the ball or someone beings
and get this at fortydays diversions
european or previous alphago version
en de previously published work
better version a hundred two zero
this has kept for several nights nou en
die and completely out of being in
dispersion de  tour euro networks of
fused into one which can be trained more
efficiently
you this beautiful to see this course as
they show so neural network star thing
for me around initialization
the north roles at beyond that it is
completely odd jobs what the game myself in
this rapidly become  spoke teakolie
unbeatable
and he explains the best part for less uses
only one single
machine the thinking so far file that is
history and folding before ice watch
time to be your life
congratulations by the deep my team
for this remarkable achievement and
family and loft [ __ ] was research  to
my de radio's en het's het troop
privilege to be able to linguistics
trio
thank you very much for your genero  us
support om peter jan and may be able to
spend more and more time while of most
absolutely amazing and now and a little
bit redundant wat muscle memory and
sign out to use or die for watching and
for your generous support and i'll see
you next time
[Music]